we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
and i have been getting many voicemails
and emails like this one this one
happens to be from the eggman
very pleased with the recent changes to
the david pakman show call
segments take a listen to this from the
eggman hey dave
in the past when you would take phone
calls that was my least favorite part of
the show
but lately i've been loving it i love
your international
calls i get so excited i just want to
say singapore and vienna were your
greatest calls this week
i'm dying laughing i love the
international calls
also your new phone system sounds great
with these uh
these callers on friday shalom brother
happy bangla all right yes shalom and
everybody celebrate i call it hanukkah
he seemed to call it something else
um but uh i i have been so
anytime we do anything some people
become irate with me
but we've switched our call system from
a phone system
to a web-based system through discord at
discore at
davidpakman.com discord call quality in
terms of
audio quality has gone up call quality
in terms of the diversity
of callers has gone up we also have the
ability to do more
screening of callers and have people
communicate what they want to ask about
if we want
i think it's been a dramatic improvement
i still have some people who are really
really mad
some who say they don't use this scored
so they can't call
discord's free you could just use it um
or not
it's also not mandatory to call in um a
couple of other complaints that now i'm
i'm not really
remembering but people there's always a
contingent that's mad but i think it has
been a dramatic improvement and we've
been hearing from callers i mean just
last week we had singapore
we had austria we had saudi arabia or as
trump says it's saudi
and what else we many callers from latin
america so that's
all great stuff and there's this whole
other discussion forum on discord as
well which you can find at
davidpakman.com
slash discord on today's bonus show
california is proposing some new rules
for police officers where you either
have to be
at least 25 years old or
have a bachelor's degree the idea i
believe
is that a disproportionate number of the
bad cop complaints are some of the very
young officers
often without college degrees so if you
say the only way to be an officer
is uh if you're under 25 is to have a
bachelor's degree
you could maybe eliminate that now of
course there are arguments on the other
side that this is
unfairly removing a large swath of
possible
officers because of what may be an
economic
hardship preventing them from getting a
college degree so we're going to talk
about that
and the implications on the bonus show
we will talk about the violence and
arrests
at the trump supporter rally in
washington dc
over the weekend there was a lot of
insanity and we will also talk about
another sports team this time it's the
cleveland baseball team
which is dropping the indian nickname
after much controversy we saw washington
redskins become
i believe now they're just the
washington football team so we will talk
about that and its implications and more
get instant access to this great bonus
show by becoming a member at
joinpacman.com
and remember that on january 121
1121 we will have a
huge membership special
for which you need only get on our
newsletter mailing list at
davidpakman.com to be notified on the
first day of the new year
about this wild membership special i'll
see you then